welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we break down all the
latest movies game releases TV shows and
comic books in this episode we're going
to be breaking down the sequel to what
is in my opinion and the greatest movie
of all time throughout this video I'll
be discussing everything that you need
to know about dr. sleep including its
plot and ending make sure you stick
around until the end where I'll be
letting you know whether the movie
shines or if it's a sequel that you
should overlook there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch the movie yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of dr. sleep okay
so dr. sleep is both a sequel to the
original shining novella by Stephen King
as well as the film adaptation by
Stanley Kubrick even though there are
several aspects in both that differs
slightly dr. sleep manages to meld the
two entities into one continuity that
pleases fans of both in case you haven't
seen or read The Shining I thought I'd
give a high-level plot overview of the
story just to quickly get you up to
speed if you're only here for spoilers
this is a very basic outline and the
film especially is worth checking out if
you haven't because it's an absolute
masterpiece so the shining follows Jack
Torrance his wife Wendy and son Danny
who has an imaginary friend named Tony
Jack has been tasked with being a
caretaker of the Overlook Hotel in the
Rocky Mountains and throughout the
winter his sanity slowly starts to slip
and he turns on his family attempting to
murder them in the film Danny learns
from a chef at the hotel named dick
Halloran that he has a psychic ability
known as shining that allows him to see
ghosts and supernatural elements that
are part of the location after being
chased by Jack Danny and Wendy managed
to get away leaving Jack to freeze to
death in the hotel's maze at the close
of the movie whilst I thought that on
the whole the shining was very ambiguous
over whether the ghosts were real or not
outside of one pivotal scene
dr. sleep flat-out confirms that these
things did indeed happen the way that we
the viewer and Jack saw them with the
evil spirits behind the hotel being a
main driving force of his since
dr. sleep picks up not long after the
events of the shining with Danny still
haunted by the spirits of the Overlook
that are continuously trying to feast
upon him with the ghost of dick Halloran
as his guide he's able to create mental
boxes that can entombed the spirits and
he goes through his childhood trapping
them one by one though you would think
that Danny would live a happy life after
catching them all this isn't the case
and he's grown up traumatized by the
events that happened at the Overlook and
his abilities turning to alcohol in
order to make his mind numb to the
things around him this all comes to a
head when we jumped at two thousand
eleven and Danny is involved in the
death of a one night stand who overdoses
Danny sees that she has a child and he
neglects checking on whether she is
breathing thus leaving him to die as
well
it's a turn that I really didn't expect
and throughout the film I kept
second-guessing whether it was all the
trick or if Danny had really made a huge
mistake that led to the death of an
infant though I was initially extremely
uncomfortable with the idea of it I was
reminded throughout the film that this
is a universe that doesn't pull any
punches when it comes to killing kids
and even though that one kid did deserve
to die for what he did to the predator
it felt instantly adult and as dark of a
world as the characters stated in order
to get away from his guilt
Danny moves to another town where he
lives a life of sobriety for Meniere's
after befriending a man named Billy
there's an awesome call back to the
overlock office when Danny is attempting
to get a job and he ends up operating as
a hospital orderly that goes by the
nickname dr. sleep this is due to the
fact that he eases those who are a debt
store by calming them with stories about
how going to the afterlife is like
drifting off to sleep it's clear he's
keeping his head down and just wants an
easy uneventful life but he is pulled
into a world of danger once more when he
encounters the character Abra a young
teen who like him has the ability to
shine Abra has unwittingly become a
target of the true not a cult of psychic
vampires led by a character named rose
the Hat that beat off people with the
ability to tap into the spiritual world
this draining of their life force allows
the true not texts in their lifespan as
long as they continue to feed and feed
they do I was pretty shocked by just how
depraved the movie gets at points and
quickly the true not become the kind of
people
you just want to get as far away as
possible from Abra is an extremely
strong psychic and thus feasting upon
her will grant them an even further
extended lifespan that they can live off
for centuries the true not inhale as
psychics quote/unquote steam during
their death and the more pain and agony
they cause the better whilst the opening
hour of doctors sleep is quite slow and
most might be put off by the pacing it's
purposely drawn out to develop these
characters and give their motives for
the paths that they take in the movie
Danny is a coward and the struggles when
it comes to admitting that they need to
be stopped where is the true not due to
the dwindling psychics that now exist in
the world
have grown desperate and even more
extreme tracking down their targets with
an almost terminate alike mindset Abra
pleads with Danny who initially advises
her to hide like him but after he speaks
to dick once more he realizes that they
will simply keep coming until the girl
dies a brutal drawn-out death and he
knows that there is no real option but
to take them head-on
and repay the debt for letting the child
earlier in the movie and his mother die
with a help of Billy they draw the true
not out of the woods using Abra as bait
and shoot them all one by one this is
where the movie really kicks it up a
notch
absolutely loved how the plan was just
to stand behind some trees and sniper
them like it's nothing
boom headshot however not everything
goes Danny in APRA's way and Billy ends
up killing himself after one of the
psychics that is known as a pusher
Wilson into doing it one of the true
knots forces known as the crow to had
their own diversion and they break into
APRA's house kill his father and
kidnapper I did know as the Abra lived
at house 1980 as well which i think is a
clear call back to the year that the
shining was made anyway while she is
able to get out of the situation due to
help from Danny they realize that there
is only one way to stop Rose the Hat and
that is to lure her to the Overlook in
the hopes that the ghosts there will
feast on her it's an awesome premise for
the finale and watching Danny take that
long drive up to the isolated location
was not only a trip down memory lane for
the characters but also the viewers the
creative team really nailed all of the
nuances of this journey and the blaring
orchestral score really got me hyped as
they arrived at the hotel for the final
act here Danny tells abre to
whilst he goes and powers of the hotel
and reawakens was within it watching him
paced through the hallways and all of
the iconic settings is a real blast and
it feels like pure fan service that
delivers in all of the right ways adding
authenticity to the piece
Danny turns on the boiler visits the
bathroom where the infamous here's
Johnny scene took place and then goes to
the Gold Room bar where he comes face to
face with his father who is now in the
position of Lloyd the barman now people
have theorized for decades where the
Jack was absorbed into the hotel or not
due to the ending of The Shining and
this scene indeed confirms that he has
become a slave to the location similar
to Delbert Grady before him and many of
the ghosts that we see throughout the
movie Jack offers Danny a drink stating
that it's medicine that will help the
cure the sickness of life but Danny
turns it down
sending Jack into an angry rage that has
him drinking the alcohol that he poured
out for the character this scene is
brilliant and it's an absolute
picture-perfect recreation of the
original scene from The Shining though
the actors slightly resembles Jack
Nicholson he really carries with him an
undertone of the character that embodies
the exact kind of person that Jack was
which in reflection cements exactly what
kind of person Danny is it's a real
closing of the book on their
relationship and it reminds us that
Danny even though he exhibited many
characteristics of his father is not him
and thus he leaves the bar ready to take
rose head-on with the help of Abra they
battle a villain taking her mentally to
the hedge maze where Danny has kept all
of the spirits of the Overlook trapped
in his mind though she escapes and we
get an awesome staircase scene that has
a brilliant callback to the original
Danny ends up unleashing the spirits on
Rose and they consumer
however they turn their sights on Danny
and the Overlook itself possesses him
changing him into a maniac that similar
to his father chases Abra throughout the
hotel eventually arriving at room 237
where she manages to overpower the
Overlook reminding it that when Danny
arrived he turned on the boiler for
those who don't know in the original
shining book the Overlook was destroyed
at the end of it due to the boiler
exploding and know this wasn't brought
across of the film this kind of brings
it full circle and watches Danny rushes
to the basement whilst Abra is
to escape outside Danny finally frees
himself of the hotel and in the boiler
room is joined by the spirit of his
mother as the avila goes up in flames
was a bruh watches from the outside back
home Abra discusses with Danny how she
thought that he went up in flames with
the location and she worries that the
world is full of people worse than Rose
who may come for her
however Danny reminds her that the world
is also full of people like her and that
there are ways to fight the darkness
Abra's mother calls for her and asks who
she was talking to you which is when we
realized that Danny indeed died with the
hotel and is now acting as a mentor to
the girl similar to how dick did with
him Abra initially denies speaking to
anyone but then admits to her mother
that she was speaking to Danny and
informs her that there is an afterlife
and that her father grandmother and
Danny are all there in happiness now The
Shining and dr. sleep both explore how
violence is cyclical for example those
who go through violence as children
often end up being aggressive adults and
thus Danny sacrifice is an attempt to
break this cycle so that he does not
become his father this might not
completely remove the world of all its
evil but it may make a place that shines
slightly brighter the world is often
called a dark place throughout the film
but this sacrifice at least brings some
light to it before going downstairs Abra
goes to the bathroom and we see that she
is greeted by the lady in the bath who
she will no doubt trap in her own mental
boxes the spirits of the Overlook are
still out there and are probably coming
for her but now she knows what to do and
unlike Danny she will not run in fear
from them but rather embrace who she is
and take them head-on righting the
wrongs of his past and making the world
a safer place for psychics that ends the
film and closes out the shining saga
with a satisfying ending that definitely
leaves the viewer with a real sense of
hope but what did I think about dr.
sleep overall well going into the film I
was very very anxious and worried that
this was going to be a big
disappointment as I mentioned earlier
the shining is my favorite film of all
time and I've done a couple of in-depth
analysis videos of it over the years
that have really gotten to the core of
it and I absolutely loved it needless to
say it's an amazing movie
with a lot of layers in it and building
up to this the fact that they were not
only trying to do a sequel to that but
also the book had me very much in the
mindset that they would fall flat on
their faces or their own axes that
doesn't really work however I'm pleased
to say that dr. sleep is a brilliant
movie and it's not only one of the best
Stephen King adaptations ever made it's
also the best horror movie of the air
Mike Flanagan the creator of the
haunting of Hell House on Netflix has
cemented himself as one of the best
horror directors out there and from the
off he grounds the piece in an
atmosphere that really elevates the
movie and sent chills down my spine this
was an impossible task given to the
creator that required a lot from him
but he quite comfortably surpassed all
of my expectations this is in part due
to the phenomenal cast who really nailed
down all of the nuances of the source
material and even with many of the
recasts that I imagined to take me out
of it I'm happy to say that they
completely knocked it out of the park
least of all Rebecca Ferguson who does a
terrific job as Rose the Hat she's
creepy charismatic and just has
something going on beneath the surface
that makes her unknowingly terrifying
but was too ding The Shining for
anything it would be that the villains
in it or rather the ghosts didn't feel
as threatening as they could be because
they didn't really possess any
physicality and thus they had to
manipulate Jack and Dee carrying out
their bidding juxtaposing this the true
not are very much alive and therefore a
real force to be reckoned with from the
off this all adds towards an outstanding
piece that whilst falls slightly short
the kubrik version still has a lot going
on that makes it a real triumph
dr. Sleep earns its status as a worthy
successor to the shiny which is a big
big statement for me to be making this
should have failed it should have been a
disappointment but everyone has pulled
something together that is very very
special I thoroughly enjoyed dr. sleep
and that's why he gets an 8.5 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on dr. sleep and if you agree
with my thoughts on the movie or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the Halloween timeline
which would be linked at the end we went
through the full watching order with
Halloween expert
champagne so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey will head
over to my discord server which should
be linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with all the latest videos on the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 1
boxer on blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
dr. sleep in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of November and the set will be shipped
out from the end to ever gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you